[Music]
23 years ago today Hong Kong was
returned to China by the UK thanks to
the new national security law it has
never been under tighter control a
picture of discipline and order exactly
what the Chinese Communist Party wants
to ensure in Hong Kong with its sweeping
legislation Cheers
all that's called for celebration and so
Hong Kong's pro-beijing leader Carrie
Lam raised a toast it is an essential
and timely decision for restoring
stability in Hong Kong the significance
of this decision is multifaceted it
shows that the central government is
determined to restore stability in Hong
Kong after a year of escalating violence
and riots since last year but Hong
Kong's freedoms die hard they still came
out even though the cost of protest had
been raised significantly on the first
full day of the law this is a new police
flag for a new era a warning against
free speech and it didn't take long to
use this man was the first to be
arrested under the national security law
for carrying a flag that said Hong Kong
independence look closer though and the
flag says in a tiny font no to Hong Kong
independence it will be a test of the
new law and of authorities sense of
humor hitherto not renowned even though
nearly everything has changed some
things remain the same probably in the
future we may never see a million people
on the street again not because we
satisfied if the government but just
because we are now living in
but I still have hopes and do believe in
Hong Kong especially the younger
generation and the tactics were familiar
to less a police presence than an
omnipresence the water cannon promptly
deployed the so called Raptors snatch
squads at full pace and scores of
arrests the difference is that under the
new legislation the widely drawn crimes
of secession subversion terrorism and
colluding with foreign forces could
carry a life sentence last year the
numbers were bigger when there was no
national security law and no covert 19
restrictions on mass gatherings and the
March later turned violent with
protesters storming Hong Kong's
Parliament it is too soon to say how the
law will change all that much depends on
its application by police and its
interpretation by judges but if Beijing
meant to silence Hong Kong today the
people reminded the party they still
have a voice
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing